some of the weapons from your favorite
fps franchises might
not be as real as you think today we're
going to take a look at the fascinating
world of video games that have used
prototype or exceedingly rare weapons
as part of their virtual armory in some
cases taking something that never really
existed beyond
a blueprint and a box of parts and
giving them a level of fame
that they would have never otherwise
achieved utilizing the ever
knowledgeable
jonathan ferguson keeper of firearms and
artillery from the royal armories in the
uk
we're going to break down five iconic
gaming weapons that aren't as real
as you might think
[Music]
there is only one pancor jackhammer in
real life with only
three ever of being built but i'm
willing to bet you've fired way more
than that
in a bunch of different video games
it was designed to be a fully automatic
shotgun with a revolver style cylinder
and was intended to bolster a troop's
arsenal when it came to close quarters
combat
the first time i laid eyes on this thing
was while playing delta force land
warrior
in the year 2000 but this strange hunk
of metal and polymer was also usable in
far cry
battlefield 2 and 3 and even while
diving through the air
in max payne if you could somehow marry
a big drum mag
of 12 gauge ammo to a repeating or fully
automatic shotgun
in theory that would solve a close
quarter battle requirement
in reality it rarely happens that the
tactical shotgun is is needed in that in
that way
three were made the original prototype
which still survives you can find videos
and information on that online and the
other two were
tested to destruction by this company
ostensibly for the us government but as
i said
i can't find anything about that and
what we tend to find with automatic
shotguns is that they don't make it to
formal trials because
some general somewhere might think it's
a good idea and the event inventor
thinks it's a good idea but the soldiers
look at it and go
what are we gonna do with this the thing
was an utter failure
even causing the downfall of the pancor
industries company
tests proved it to be completely
unreliable reloading would often mean
taking the whole weapon apart
and they even tried to turn the cylinder
holding the shells into some kind of
strange landmine even though they would
later replace much of the system with
plastic it still weighed
a whopping 7.9 kilos or 17 pounds
to put that in perspective that is more
than two
ak-47s so why
is it so popular in our games well it
looks weird and goes
really bloody fast honestly that's the
entire reason
on paper it's a super shotgun
it's got intimidating size and
silhouette as well as the imaginary
potential to spew forth nearly a dozen
shotgun shells downrange if you were
making a shooter and you wanted
spectacle and excitement over historical
accuracy
wouldn't you have something like the
panko jack hammer
of course you would next up we've got
the german heckler and koch g11
one of the most futuristic weapons to
have ever made the leap from drawing
board
to virtual firing range it was an
experiment in a caseless ammunition
weapon system
and intended to replace west germany's
g3 service rifles from the surface it
looks like a plastic box that you force
sticks of ammunition into but a few
games thought it was enough of a selling
point to put into their game i like many
other people
are most familiar with the g11 due to
its appearance in call of duty black ops
but this weapon also showed its
futuristic face in fallout 2
and just once on the silver screen as a
futuristic beam weapon in the hands of
simon phoenix in 1993's
demolition man
in the real world however this
over-engineered weapon that looks like
it was a reject from stargate sg-1
was much more trouble than it was ever
worth vastly complicated i've heard it
described as a cuckoo clock
combined with a gun or what happens when
i think it was a
youtube comment what happens when you
give a clockmaker
class a drugs and ask him to design a
gun
it's just it's the most insane firearm
i've ever come across
and i i i did a basic field strip on one
and even that just blew my mind
the thing was in development for over 20
years and while some improvements were
made and millions of deutsche marks were
sunk into ironing out its kinks
many of the problems still remained
chief among them was that sometimes the
ammunition the weapon would just decide
to
go off if things got too hot and as the
world started to change in the late 80s
the g11 days quickly became extremely
numbered
1990 east and west germany are smashed
back together and suddenly there's
a huge budgetary issues why on earth are
we spending all this money on a space
gun
when we don't plan on going to war
anytime soon
h k gets sent back to the drawing board
and we end up with the g36
anecdotally and on paper at least it's
still interesting
it's retained that sort of old-school
science fiction vibe to it
it looks like it fell off a spaceship it
fires something called caseless
ammunition
it's no wonder that this thing that
sounds like a fictional weapon
has found more of a home in video games
than it ever did
in real life
[Music]
perhaps the most iconic example of games
utilizing prototype weaponry
is agent 47 sniper rifle of choice the
walther wa 2000
often seen either cradled in his arms
before a lethal shot or hidden and
packaged away
within his briefcase beyond its
attachment to the suit wearing chrome
dome killer
it has also made appearance in call of
duty black ops call of duty modern
warfare 2
rainbow six as well as a handful of
other games
in real life the weapon was designed in
west germany in the 1970s as a response
to the 1972
summer olympic munich massacre where the
teams tasked to take down
the terrorists from long range had
nothing but their standard issue
g3 battle rifles and their iron sights
the reaction to these events was to
found the elite police unit gsg-9
and produce a specialized marksman rifle
for counter-terrorism operations
the wa 2000. the rifle however did not
enter production until
1982 and in the six years that it was
being built
only 176 were ever created with some
being issued to german police units for
the most part however production was
stopped because it was just
far too expensive to gain widespread
sale and was passed on by the military
due to its cost
and lacking in robustness the brief was
make a semi-automatic sniper rifle uh
money is no object
and the the end result cost i think 9
000
in 1986 money i think it was which is a
lot of money now
it did what it was designed to do but
there wasn't quite enough demand
for it and there are guns that would do
the job almost as well for a lot less
money so why then has the weapon taken
on a life of its own in video games
well in the case of its virtual
appearances many titles tap into its
form over its functionality
it's certainly unique the combination of
its futuristic shape and old-school
wooden stock
makes it feel at home in every setting
from the cold war to the near future
its compact size unusual design and
rarity also make it a rifle that fits
the narrative
of a super secret assassin breaking it
apart into a suitcase
as we play as agent 47 sneaking his
munitions into a mission
or even in the hands of james bond using
it in tandem
with a license to kill so the brief for
a sort of medium range police marksman's
rifle
it's got to go fast it's got to go
accurate and that's that's what the wa
2000 achieved um
really really well with it with a short
stroke gas system rotating bolt six
round mag and of course it does look
cool it's got that
cold war mixture of almost like sci-fi
with all the black
flat faceted angles on it and then
wooden furniture
for the sort of touch of class
[Music]
[Applause]
dorian lang is confirmed killed the
money will be wired to your account in a
moment
the fmg9 was the bane of many call of
duty modern warfare 3 players
as in 2011 it was a common sight to see
the makimbo style
as operatives ran across maps and
hip-fired every round they could
it was designed by magpul a company
known more for making firearm
accessories
than they are actual weapons so far the
only version they produced
is an airsoft one fmg stands for folding
submachine gun and the intention was to
be able to disguise these things as a
small package
or something the size of a laptop
battery with the goal of appealing to
close protection details like the united
states secret service
or private security companies instead
many of these private security
organizations decided hmm maybe it's
better if we just
do our job instead of wasting time
playing with a transformer
in a vain attempt to get a weapon out
the real world applications of this
are really quite few so if people aren't
clear what we're talking about this is
basically this is a pistol or a fully
automatic pistol
or mechanism thereof in a boxy shell
and it folds up on itself so it looks
just like a brick or
like a radio if you wish what this boils
down to though
is it's far quicker we've all seen john
wick you can see how quickly you can
draw a pistol from concealment
present it and pull the trigger it's
always going to be quicker
than unfolding a gun it seems that its
appearance in modern warfare 3
battlefield hardline and rainbow six
siege is a reactionary move
on the part of the developers it was a
very new idea with a modern and tactical
thought process behind it
so before it even entered production it
made sense that it was thrown into
shooters that fit the same aesthetic and
setting
but since its last addition to a game
was back in 2015
he appears to have lost favor with the
world of video games just as quickly
as it gained it the objective individual
combat weapon
or oicw was an attempt for the us army
to create their next generation of
rifles during the 1980s
and this project somehow retained
support for 30 years
the most infamous entry of the program
is the xm290icw
the overgrown love child of a 20
millimeter grenade launcher and a 5.56
millimeter rifle
always makes me think of the massive gun
with a microwave and a stereo and a net
launcher on it from beverly hills cop3
you can make popcorn and shoot fire and
rockets out of it
the unique selling point of this thing
was that the grenade launch component of
the weapon would be able to fire a
smart air burst system that fired
programmable munitions
capable of hitting an enemy behind or
through cover the idea is to deny
cover obviously first thing you do when
you get shot at is you hide behind
something
so a the enemy can't see you to hit you
more importantly b
they're bullets grenades whatever
they're throwing at you shooting at you
can't hit you because sand earth
brick rock whatever will stop or slow
down bullets so the idea of the grenade
part of oicw and anything like this
was to just go well we'll just go around
it we'll go over it so the the giant
bullet effectively would
fly over the cover and then explode over
the guy hiding behind it or it would
punch
through a wooden door or through a
drywall and then explode
now if that sounds like something out of
a science fiction movie well that's
because you might have seen the same
design principles in the 1986
blockbuster aliens
specifically the m41a pulse rifle a
fictional gun i covered extensively in a
previous episode of loadout
the idea of such a massive weapon
containing a grenade launcher
a computer and the assault rifle part
makes it a natural fit to be put in to
the larger than life
video games and while it's been a while
since the weapon has made a virtual
appearance
the aspects that made it a popular pick
between 1999 and 2006
are still utilized today smart
programmable weapons instantly add a
touch of futuristic tech to any arsenal
and the idea of having an alternate fire
or combining two weapons
into one over the top powerful platform
is something we see
in many a hero shooter an action game
today in the real world the xm29 never
really went anywhere it was considered
too big and bulky and heavy for
widespread deployment but the upside is
that the project
was put into separate other weapons that
became much more
than the original sum of its parts the
xm25 grenade launcher an ironically
named the punisher and seen in modern
warfare 3 and battlefield 4
was born from the explosive munition
portion of the xm29
after it was carved off into its own
entity the rifle components however led
to the production of the xm8
which many of you may recognize from
battlefield bad company 2
and while the hope was that it would be
adopted by the us military it instead
eventually found a home in the barracks
of the royal malaysian navy
in the end the lofty goals of the oic
program ended up being out of reach
for the technology of its time but the
silver lining was that it has made for
some bloody cool video game weapons
there's a lot of merit to the concept
and we see this time and time again with
prototype
developmental weapons is people mean
well
they try really hard but they try to do
too much and that's really the story of
the oicw
thank you so much for watching our look
at some of the larger than life
prototypes that have made the jump from
drawing board
to virtual armory i'm sure there's lots
that we weren't able to go into today
so if you have a favorite that we
haven't talked about leave it in the
comments section below
and i'll do my best to take a look at
all them i always enjoy conversating
with other
virtual weapons nerds and we're still
working on plenty of other loader
episodes to come
so to be sure that you don't miss those
make sure you subscribe to gamespot